if you can't speak honestly about facts
that everyone can observe or that it
takes five minutes to surface you know
it's just what is the path here to not
alienating
a majority of people because it's not
just a matter of not speaking honestly
it's it's castigating fully half of a
society on many of these points as
racists or sexist or misogynists or you
know xenophobes and I may begin to take
take another topic immigration of course
it's possible to be concerned about
immigration from a racist white
supremacist xenophobic perspective that
does not mean that that that genuine
concern about immigration is always
motivated by those sins right I mean
like it is as far as I can tell it is
only sane to want a defensible border
right and to want to know who's coming
into the country and to want to be able
to admit the people into the country who
you want into the country you know and
like why not have a policy that allows
for that well on the left you begin to
sound like a racist [ __ ] arguing for
a policy like that I don't know I guess
that's because you're calling one that's
been III again I think that that's a
relatively small but everybody who calls
my show and talks about this immigration
issue is starting from exactly that
point that you're starting from which is
countries exist if we recognize that
countries exist there's got to be a
process there has to be a border and I
feel like there there's probably more
reasonable conversation happening about
that then maybe is highlighted in
corporate media but but but it was but
again it's not even highlighted at the
level of the you know the Democratic
debates I mean virtually every candidate
had a either explicit or implicit open
borders policy no see I don't see that
at all that's interesting that I did not
I actually didn't couldn't identify a
single candidate that had an effective
open borders policy well well it was a
sent immediately they got to the punch
line when when asked you know what what
do you do with respect to medical
for people who get in and and it was
again this is this is to some degree
just a response to the emergency of
Trump right and we have we've got you
know kids being put in cages at the
border and now now our debate about
immigration is being held in that
context yeah but it seemed to be that
you know we were gonna give lifetime
free medical care to anyone who could
just get into the country okay now
that's funny that you mentioned that
because the day after I said this is a
losing issue for Democrats the the idea
of you know the hand raising about what
we want I actually just don't know that
that was even the way the issue should
have been framed but you're completely
right and I literally said that I think
within hours of the debate I said this
is this is a way to lose the Trump which
is starting to talk about about this as
the priority when there are so many
other things that actually should be the
priorities